der hyper look scheint wirklich
unaufhaltsam zu sein entgegen allen
skeptikern klappt alles wie am
schnürchen und nachdem anfang des jahres
der startschuss für die erste
europäische teststrecke gefallen ist
gibt es jetzt schon die erste fahrfähige
kapsel zu bestaunen wie was wo jetzt in
klicks um science-fiction in den e on
mars chroniken hier gibt es täglich
science videos abonniert den kanal dort
verpasst ihr nichts herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
vielen mass idee eines
hochgeschwindigkeit transportsystems
durch vakuumröhren scheint doch gar
nicht so schlecht gewesen zu sein
die entwicklung scheint richtig schnell
an fahrt aufzunehmen und das im wahrsten
sinne des wortes er selbst ist ja nur am
rande damit befasst kommerziell
entwickelt wird der heimklub dagegen von
firmen die gar nichts mit max
firmenimperium zu tun haben eine davon
ist hyper loop transportation
technologies hyper looked at t und die
haben jetzt die erste kapsel vorgestellt
de kall borneo von heiko lugt idee dazu
war haimanot geht es um mehr als
schnelle beschleunigung und das brechen
von geschwindigkeitsrekorden es ist eine
echte chance ein effizientes und
sicheres system mit einem einzigartigen
erlebnis für die reisenden zu erschaffen
und maske hatte die bahnbrechende idee
aber gab sie frei jeder darf entwickeln
und bauen
und die idee super einfach rohrpost und
die könnte der magnetschwebetechnik
jetzt im nachhinein zum erfolg verhelfen
beim transrapid hat es ja nicht so
richtig geklappt das prinzip der zug
oder beim piper loop eine katze wird in
eine röhre gepackt und in der herrscht
ein vakuum bzw
ist kaum noch luft enthalten ein
sogenanntes teil warum
hochleistungspumpen pumpen die luft auf
der röhre und erhalten das vakuum der
effekt es gibt keinen luftwiderstand
mehr das hauptproblem und der
energiefresser jedes schnellen
transportes das ist einfach weg
damit brauche ich für den zug kaum noch
energie ist er einmal beschleunigte
sollen solarzellen auf den
transporteuren ausreichen um für die
energie zusammen mit rund 1200 kilometer
pro stunde soll er zwischen metropolen
verkehr schneller als mit einem flug ton
und maske hält sich bei der entwicklung
eben vollkommen raus und besuch
vielleicht mal ein
standorte der konkurrenten denn auch
virgin chef richard branson ist man
wieder mit am start er hat das zweite
unternehmen das am hyper luft dran ist
gekauft aus heilbronn wurde virgin blue
band ja mal sehen wer das rennen hier
macht auf jeden fall hat hyper lobt die
jetzt mit der neuen kapsel die nase vorn
die neue kapsel quintero wann ist rund
32 meter lang wiegt 5 tonnen und enthält
eine 15 meter lange passagierkabine die
ist allerdings noch gar nicht
eingerichtet gefertigt ist sie aus wie
braun ihm nicht von ungefähr heißt es
dieses material genauso wie das aus dem
das schild von captain america gefertigt
ist doch es ist ganz normalen irdischen
ursprungs entwickelt wurde es von dem
slowakischen unternehmen 2
es zeichnet sich durch eine besondere
härte und steifigkeit aus es besteht aus
kohlefasern ist also besonders leicht
und zehn mal härter als stahl und
zweieinhalb mal so steigt wie aluminium
darüber hinaus ist es mit sensoren
durchsetzen die die hülle ständig auf
temperaturstabilität und schäden
untersuchen zudem ist die hülle der
kapsel mehrschichtig also selbst wenn
etwas passiert bleibt sie sicher dabei
soll eine neue magnetschwebetechnik
eingesetzt werden bei der deutlich
weniger energie verbraucht wird
permanentmagneten die im sogenannten
halbach angeordnet sind sollen zum einen
die magnetkraft in die kapsel nahezu auf
null reduzieren und im gegenzug unten
zum transport track verstärken indirekt
heißt die technik die von hyper lob
transportation technologies angewendet
wird und auf der teststrecke mit dieser
technologie in toulouse in frankreich
soll jetzt die neue kapsel zum ersten
mal getestet werden sie ist erst mal
nicht besonders langen diese teststrecke
320 meter die röhren haben einen
durchmesser von vier metern und sind
damit für güter und auch schon für den
personentransport geeignet aber hier
kann schon getestet werden im nächsten
jahr soll dann eine längere teststrecke
fertig werden wo der quintero wandern
auch zum ersten mal passagieren
transportieren wird wo der hype allouche
ein schneller realität zu werden als so
mancher vermutet hätte ich bleibe auf
jeden fall dran und wenn er als erstes
neues zum hyper lob und zu allen anderen
themen erfahren wollt denn endet meine
telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp dann
erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen
vom neuesten video tägliche und
garantiert und zur überprüfung
noch ein kleines geschenk einfach hier
draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo
mit der glocke vergessen und darunter
geht es weiter mit
dafür auch draufklicken helfer luke
deutsche strecke geplant ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran